here are the stories of some of the most
popular shows about cool teenagers that
aired in the 1990s
and the reasons they had to grow up move
on and leave the airwaves
good morning miss bliss a short-lived
disney channel vehicle for former child
star haley mills about an indiana
teacher was revamped by nbc
into saved by the bell a show about
super cool bayside california teen
zack morris the fourth wall breaking
ferris bueller-like character was
supported in his schemes by his
inner circle mega nerd screech jock ac
slater
fashionista lisa turtle overachiever
jesse spano and sometimes girlfriend
kelly kapowski
they also had a band called the zak
attack and hung out in a diner called
the max run by a magician
saved by the bell was kind of weird but
it was a smash hit on nbc's saturday
morning schedule from 1989 to 1993.
so why did it have to end i'm sorry zack
i wish there was a way we could still
put on the show so you could be in it
the characters on the show aged in real
time and four years is as long as high
school lasts
not only were they scheduled to move on
from bayside high but tiffany thiessen
and elizabeth berkley left the show
midway through the 1992-1993 season
nbc wasn't ready to say goodbye so it
launched the prime time continuation
saved by the bell the college years
which found
zack out of his element as a freshman at
california university
along with most of his high school
friends viewers apparently
weren't interested in a non-bayside high
bell and the show bombed
ranking at number 88 in the ratings for
the 1993-94 season
which was its only season undaunted the
studio launched yet another spin-off
saved by the bell the new class which
actually ended up outlasting every other
iteration of the show during its 7
season run
proving your high school years are
always a part of you members of the
original cast reunited for a saved by
the bell revival in 2020 streaming on
nbc's peacock platform
beverly hills 90210 was arguably the
starting point and inspiration for all
90s teen culture not long after its
premiere on fox in 1990 the soap became
the hottest show on the air for millions
of young americans
fans needed to know what happened in the
social lives of brandon and brenda walsh
minnesota transplants who moved to a
certain ritzy los
angeles suburb along with their various
friends and romantic partners
brenda's relationship with dylan became
iconic for millions of teens
who bought magazines and posters
featuring the show's photogenic cast
beverly hills 90210 proved so popular
and vital to the rise and continued
success of fox that the network kept it
on the air
it evolved from a high school show to a
college show then simply one about the
lives of young adults
by the year 2000 10 years after its
debut 90210 was the longest running
drama on american nighttime tv
although much of the original cast had
long since left and been replaced by new
similarly good looking people with the
show long in the tooth and its
characters nearing their 30s
fox cancelled the once mighty teen soap
after nearly 300 episodes
like many long running series beverly
hills 90210 spawned a series of
spin-offs
the most popular of which melrose place
became one of the defining shows of its
era in its own right
that tradition continued in 2008 with
90210 a spin-off that focused on the
lives of a different group of teens in
the ritzy area code
after that show left the air in 2013 yet
another series
bh 90210 reunited the original cast in
2019
this time with the actors playing
fictionalized versions of themselves
it's an appealingly weird idea but
viewers weren't interested bh90210 left
the airwaves after
only six episodes now we get to sit
around and wait and see if we get picked
up oh that's a formality right i mean
it's the reboot of 90210 no brainer
at the peak of beverly hills 90210
success came my so-called life an
extremely low-key drama about a girl
right in the middle of the social chain
struggling with adolescence and her
parents expectations and perceptions of
her stories told with copious narration
from fifteen-year-old claire danes who
starred as quiet introspective
angela chase i've been kissed three
times
no four times no
three times the show became a cult hit
and critical darling praise for its
sensitive
non-condescending and realistic
portrayal of teenage life and danes
became one of the youngest performers to
ever be nominated in a lead acting
category at the emmy awards
however my so-called life was not even
remotely a hit
ranking as the 116th most watched show
of the 1994
1995 tv season and the least watched
program on abc overall
that's probably because the network
scheduled it thursdays at 8 against
nbc's juggernaut must-see tv sitcom
lineup
my so-called life went head-to-head with
matt about you and a brand new sitcom
called friends
which would become iconic for the
generation at whom my so-called life was
directed
after one season abc canceled its
groundbreaking teen drama
when clarissa explains it all hit
nickelodeon in 1991
it was like nothing else on tv at the
time melissa joan hart starred as
adolescent clarissa darling who talked
to the audience to explain her life the
actions of others
and any other number of quirks of the
human existence
clarissa became a role model for her
creative flair abundant confidence and
wacky sense of humor
plus viewers could relate to the trials
of having goofy parents and an annoying
little brother
during clarissa explains it all's fourth
season nickelodeon decided that it
wasn't going to order more episodes
why at 17 the character of clarissa was
too old to be starring in a nickelodeon
show but
not cool enough to star in a show on
sibling network mtv
creator mitchell kriegman told mental
floss in those days nickelodeon stopped
at 14 and
mtv started at 15 or 16 and there was no
middle ground
they didn't cross that line because that
was mtv territory and the attitude of
mtv was way different than the attitude
of nickelodeon
kriegman attempted to skip the
demographic pigeonholing altogether and
in 1995
pitched to cbs a continuation called
clarissa in which the college age title
character lands an internship at a new
york newspaper
it never became a series the early fox
network took some chances airing shows
far edgier and
more unusual than the stuff seen on the
other major broadcast networks
in 1990 it aired the surreal high school
comedy parker lewis can't lose
later shortened to just parker lewis the
show starred korn and nemik as an
extremely cool teen doing constant
battle with his principal with the help
of his friends
a rocker named mikey and a nerd named
jerry whose trench coat pockets held a
treasury of bizarre gadgets
shot in the film-like single camera
format when studio audiences and laugh
tracks were the norm
parker lewis's quick cuts weird camera
angles and special effects certainly put
it ahead of its time
after three seasons both show and
network were changing rapidly
co-creator clyde phillips told the
hollywood reporter the danger when you
do a high school show is that your
characters have to grow and in fact they
have to grow out of high school
as for fox the network was quote looking
a bit to get more adult
co-creator lon diamond said explaining
that the network was at the time aiming
for more serious teen content
fox pulled the plug in 1993 after three
seasons
teenage singer brandi was everywhere in
the mid 90s releasing a slew of r
b tinged pop smashes like i want to be
down baby and the boy is mine
in 1996 upn capitalized on brandy's high
status with teenagers and gave her a
sitcom
signing her to star on moisha as moisha
a los
angeles teen going through the normal
trials and tribulations of american
adolescent life
at a big event in new york's madison
square garden in may 2001 upn announced
its big moves for its slate of
programming set to debut the following
fall
it was nothing short of an overhaul what
with the cancellations of its two
longest running shows star trek voyager
which had been on the air since 1995 and
moesha ending its five-year run
the reason moisha had quote run its
course according
to ceo dean valentine who said it was
time to freshen up the night
getting rid of moishe may have also been
a way to make room and set aside some
cash
during the same media con fab where the
show was officially canceled upn
announced that it had acquired two
series from
rival mini network the wb roswell and
buffy the vampire slayer most movies and
teen shows about teens are about the
rich and popular kids
mtv's animated hit daria had plenty of
those characters
except that they were a source of
derision for the heroes
brutally sarcastic and proud social
pariah daria morgendorffer and her best
friend
aspiring painter jane the series
brutally mocked high school and all its
social conventions with daria delivering
her vicious and pointed criticisms at
the jocks cheerleaders and her
popularity obsessed sister quinn
you can't go you'll ruin everything you
know
i really should broaden my social
horizons daria which debuted in 1997 as
a spin-off of mtv's beavis and butthead
came about when the network needed a
show to attract female audiences
showrunner glenn eichler was left mostly
to his own devices
and mtv offered him and his team full
creative freedom to make the show they
wanted
that also meant he got to end it on his
own terms when he was ready and he
wrapped up after five seasons with a tv
movie about daria's graduation
but there's a good chance daria wouldn't
have made it to another season even if
eichler had wanted to do
that he told variety not too long after
the series ended mtv animation imploded
so i don't know if we would have even
made it to a sixth year
ryan murphy has created a lot of shows
in addition to provocative stuff for
grownups like nip tuck
pose and american horror story he's
probably best known for getting glee on
the air
but he honed his teen tv chops with his
first ever series the darkly comic high
school so
popular which hit the wb in 1999. it was
about two very different teenagers
cheerleader brooke and school newspaper
editor sam forced into togetherness when
their respective single parents marry
popular seemingly fit right in with the
wb's late 90s lineup of teen fare like
dawson's creek and roswell
but murphy later claimed that there was
a disconnect between his progressive
vision for the show and what the network
wanted it to be
he told entertainment weekly they never
got me
and they kept trying to turn me into
something else they would give me notes
like
the mary cherry character like could she
be less gay
even though i'm depressed and feel life
has no meaning since that editorial
this restroom always makes me feel so
pretty overall he quote didn't have a
good experience making popular
despite his following the network's
every suggestion the show still got
cancelled after two years anyway
the hit 1995 movie clueless concerned a
close-obsessed beverly hills teen named
share horowitz who just wants to get her
driver's license
hang out with her friend dion and give
new student tai a life-changing makeover
the cheery and casual dynamic along with
the film's popularity made a tv version
almost
a foregone conclusion and clueless the
show wound up on abc's tgif lineup in
the fall of 1996.
several cast members of the film
reprised their roles while rachel
blanchard took over for alicia
silverstone as the lead
despite moderately high ratings it
ranked number 53 for the year
abc canceled it only for the team
skewing upn to seize it
the change in venue to the generally
little watched smaller network hurt the
show
viewership fell and after the third
season of clueless saw another ratings
drop upn canceled the show
buffy a vampire slayer played by sarah
michelle gellar
constantly faced danger violence and
death in the line of duty
and buffy the vampire slayer of the show
outlasted almost as many threats
it survived a rescinded cancellation the
second death of the title character
a network switch from the wb to upn the
exit of popular characters angel and
cordelia to the spin-off angel
and consistently poor ratings never
ranking higher than 120th place in the
annual nielsen tally
nevertheless buffy's crew produced 144
episodes of what would become one of the
biggest cult shows of all time
chock full of action stunts and serious
acting
that amounted to a tremendous grind for
geller and by 2003
she'd had enough i quit i resign
i'm fired she told entertainment weekly
i'm 26 i'm married i never see my
husband
you want to pick up and go try other
things live in different places
it feels right and you have to listen to
that without buffy there could be no
buffy
and so upn wrapped up the series check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]